welcome back to pft
pm joining us now quarterback of
minnesota vikings he's
kirk cousins on behalf of sleep number
kirk how are you pal
tone well mike good to see you hey great
to see you and it just seems like
yesterday that we were talking to you in
minnesota
before you'd signed with the vikings
three years
have now gone by what's been the biggest
thing
that you've learned during your three
years with the vikings
well i'm just so grateful that i got the
chance to come here to minnesota and to
play with people like adam thielen and
justin jefferson and kyle rudolph and
dalvin cook and
on and on and to uh you know get to
cross paths with kevin stefanski and
gary kubiak and mike zimmer
i just feel fortunate to be in the
position i'm in i think minnesota is a
great organization i think we have a
great locker room and
we fell a little short this past season
but i'm excited about 2021 and what
we're building
we talked to justin jefferson yesterday
kirk
what do you think his ceiling is based
upon what you've seen from him in just
his rookie year without that normal
opportunity to prepare like a rookie
ordinarily would have had
well i think that's what's so remarkable
about his rookie season is that he did
not have otas he didn't have a normal
training camp we didn't really plug him
in as our starting x until week three
and he was still able to go for 1400
yards and i believe set the rookie
record
four yards in a season receiving so
tremendous year i mean if he could do
what he did this past year as a rookie
and just keep doing that year after year
after year
he's going to be in elite categories uh
you know 10 years from now
so the key is not so much reinventing
the wheel or changing what he's done
just be the consistent player he was
last year just continue to do that and
stack those years up
and he'll be looking back after you know
a long career and be pretty
pleased with what he accomplished so
he's a great teammate great player
i'm so grateful that we drafted him that
that i get to play with him
and uh he's going to help our offense go
hopefully for a long time
kirk justin jefferson is a candidate for
offense of the rookie of the year and it
was just an amazing year
and he said he credited you a lot with
his success
in his first season but he also said you
take a lot more heat than you probably
deserve to take do you agree with that
assessment
you know what i i i know that the the
phrase that i've always kind of lived by
is people who know know and people who
don't
you know i'm not going to worry too much
about what they say but fortunately
through my journey whether it was high
school getting recruited
uh college you know where i got drafted
developing there
under kyle shanahan and sean mcvay and
jay gruden and others
people who don't know and that's really
been good enough for me it's given me a
great career and giving me great
opportunities
and to the people who don't really study
it and really try to dive into the
details
you know i'm not going to spend too much
time worrying about their opinion
because i i really want to value the
opinions of the people who really do
study
i know quarterbacks spend a lot of off
seasons working on specific things a lot
of them do do you do that how will you
spend this offseason is there something
specific that you're going to work on to
get better at
i just think longevity is such an
important piece of this
uh of this job you know being able to
stay healthy being able to come back
year after year and have your body feel
good in training camp and then all the
way through the season and so
even now in you know late january early
february my focus
is you know how can i you know have my
body at now turning 33 next summer
you know continue to perform at the
level it did when i was 23 24
and um you know tom brady's obviously
set a high bar drew brees much the same
way with how well they've played into
their early 40s mid 40s even
in tom's case and just trying to have
the right habits so with my
training the workouts diets sleep i'm
here with sleep number
uh this week doing media just want to
get the word out about
you know the importance of quality sleep
and sleep number 360 smart bed that i
use and the sleep iq score that their
sleep number app provides for me
the difference it makes and and staying
healthy and having a long career so
that's really something that i try to
take seriously not only sleeping well in
season but also in the off season so i
can
hopefully play as long as a guy like
drew or tom
and you were able to make that very
seamless and professional transition to
the pitch
because you sleep on a sleep number bed
see that's how it works
the other guys can't do it the other
guys can't do it that way because
they're on a different kind of a bed
hey kirk about the off season because
we've heard different things about
different quarterbacks how much they
throw
how much do you actually pick up a
football throw a football
during that dead spot in the off season
well one off season i chose not to throw
i shut it down for about
two to three months and when i picked
the football back up in
whatever it was mid to late march i
didn't like how i felt and so i decided
from then on i'm gonna always throw
i remember when i was in washington i
got to meet max scherzer and i talked to
him a little bit about arm maintenance
and his
arm care that he's learned as a pitcher
and he said he rarely ever goes
a week without throwing a baseball even
in the off season if he goes to
fiji and goes snorkeling or scuba diving
he still brings a baseball and a glove
with him and makes sure that he throws
so
i i've kind of taken that same approach
i like to stay thrown and so
even the last few days i'll grab my
brother down the street we'll go outside
and play catch just to make sure that
i'm always throwing
and uh and i think that's a big piece of
keeping my shoulder healthy and strong
as
we get older and move forward well with
your brother is it like the old days you
go out in the street or do you own the
backyard
it's absolutely like the old days uh
although this now he's got gloves i
don't really make him catch without
gloves but uh
it's just straight in the backyard
sometimes in the driveway and again i
don't need it to be fancy i just say hey
i just need to get some throws in and
he's got good enough hands he's a good
enough athlete where i can rifle it at
him and it works for me
i'm just curious kirk you've been where
dak prescott is right now i don't know
if you've
talked to dak and given him any advice
but if if you have great but if you
haven't what advice would you give him
well the only piece i've said to him and
crossing his path that going back maybe
a couple off seasons was just to make
the point that the franchise tag
can be your friend you know it can be a
help to you if
if that's the route you choose to go um
and so you know he played on the
franchise tag this past year
i think he's in a great spot now
everybody knows he can play that he's an
elite quarterback
and um you know really the ball is more
in the in the court of
the cowboys and what they want to do
going forward but uh
i think it's a no-brainer that dax the
real deal and is going to have a great
career moving forward and
um you know he's in a really good spot
what do you think you need to do kirk to
get to that next level i know
two or three years ago you said i don't
want to be known as a 500 quarterback
to take that next step to get to a super
bowl and win a super bowl
what do you need to do well you just got
to win games there's no secret formula
you know if it was hey
i've got to complete a higher percentage
of my passes on third down
then you know you'd suddenly do that and
and you'd win i think it's just so many
variables that come into play
um but you know winning games what it's
all about that's why we play the game so
we got to stay healthy we got to keep
our best players on the field
and um we've got to win those close
games you know when you get in those
moments at the end where it comes down
to one or two plays you got to be on the
right side
of that and find those inches and i'm
optimistic that we'll be able to do that
in 2021.
kirk earlier in the interview you
mentioned gary kubiak kevin stefanski
it's just two of the offensive
coordinators you had in minnesota also
had john d filippo
this is gonna be number four and you're
entering your fourth season what kind of
a challenge does that present for you as
a quarterback
having different coordinators as often
as you have
yeah it's not ideal you would love to
have one coordinator for your whole
career
i've really had six over the last six
seasons when you go back to my final two
years in washington
it's part of the business change is is
the one constant
you have to be able to adapt and be
consistent no matter what changes around
you
fortunately i have been around really
good play callers going back to my early
days with kyle shanahan and all the way
through this past year with gary so
as much as there has been change i've
also been fortunate to have great
coaches great play callers and i expect
that whoever coach zimmer hires going
into uh this upcoming season that
it'll be no different and um you know
now going into year 10
i look forward as well to kind of taking
on more of a leadership role and
being a little bit more of a coordinator
on the field if you will
and i think you start to do that more as
you as you progress through your career
you've got three years in with the
vikings two years left under your
contract do you have
an idea in mind on how long you want to
continue to play with the vikings
well i want to be with the vikings for
as long as they'll have me and as long
as i can play football
um as far as how long i play it's so
year to year
you know we've seen so much change
happen in this league when you just look
back a year from now
or look a year ago to now um and i'm
sure a year
from now will be no different but you
know tom brady drew brees have set the
bar
so high playing into their early 40s and
i don't know that i want to play that
long but i do think that uh
to be able to play into your late 30s
and to play long enough for my two young
boys i got
two boys cooper and turner they're only
three and almost two
i'd like to play long enough where they
can you know come to practice watch me
play and really remember it and
appreciate it and so i got a few more
years to be able to do that but uh
if i can keep sleeping on my sleep
number 360 smartpak
hopefully i can be playing late and i'll
still be talking to you
uh every every so often two seamless
plugs
uh for the price of one i don't wanna
get too far into the weeds from a
business standpoint but when you look at
your contract and the way it's
structured there's reason to think that
maybe
another extension could happen this year
is there any talk of possibly extending
your stay
officially beyond 2022
no we haven't gotten there honestly i
just signed the extension last offseason
and it really doesn't kick
in until this coming year so it's a
two-year deal those two years begin
with 2021 and um you know it wasn't
really on my radar to to talk
along those lines i think it's more
about going out there next season and
the year after that and playing it
at a high enough level that would
justify being able to you know do
another deal beyond that and so that's
really where my focus is and
as i said earlier you know would like to
be a viking for the remainder of my
career and i've gotta
you know play well enough to to make
that happen
hey last one for you and as you said
nothing certain in this league we
got news over the weekend of the matthew
stafford trade out of detroit for jared
goff what was your reaction when you
heard about that
well you knew that you know matthew was
potential to move and the chair golf has
a potential to move and so
you know hopefully both organizations
feel like they got what they were
looking for in that deal but um
you know it'll be interesting to see how
detroit uses those picks going forward
and uh you know time will tell but uh
you know i think it for us affects us
because we play detroit twice a year
we've got the rams next year as well so
you know it certainly impacts our
strategy and our schedule and how we go
about it and um
you know that's typically the way it
works for this nfl news is you're always
thinking about how it affects your team
and your organization and your plans
moving forward
kirk we appreciate your time very much
congratulations on your success enjoy
your sleep number ben we look forward to
talking to you again
all right thanks guys always good to be
with you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports